okay let me just talk about where we are
right now like this is a set of your I
know talk show it's all I know it's cool
right
December 9 2010 marks the day that Lilly
Singh introduced herself to the digital
world by uploading her first youtube
video
the Scarborough native quickly grew her
platform exceeding expectations to
become one of the top content creators
in the world showcasing her multifaceted
sense of humor through sketch comedy
impressions and rap skills earning over
three billion views did you ever look
back on the old sausage if it is the
giver of ever look back at it all the
time all right so I've got 1k clicks in
the pan and we're doing my second one no
problem using pieces that is easy if you
see yourself in an old video or a clip
that someone might have called oh like
what do you think usually I'm cringing
because I do I do watch my old video
sometimes and I do see growth in just
who I am as a person and it is a
performer but it's always really special
to see it because it's not like I'm
looking back at myself and thinking oh
that's totally not me no every version
of me still seems authentic to me like
that's where I was in my life and it's
nice to go back and see where I was in
my life and how I've matured in certain
ways and how I've in matured another
before you call me hottie I'm a woman
what a story illusion
because I hustle hard like that reject
any labels I'm able to do what up please
I'll reject stable but the rise and
hustle to the top didn't come without
hurdles I am mentally physically
emotionally and spiritually exhausted
making the surprise announcement in 2018
Lily took a step back from the limelight
explaining why I don't want to take a
break there's many reasons first and
foremost my mental health too much of
anything isn't good and I've learned
about myself that hustle is great and
being involved in everything is great
until it's not great anymore to tell you
burnout and so over the past year I've
been teaching myself this word people
call balance that I wasn't but I think
is just doing little things every day
because prior to be taking a break off
social media I really did believe that
you have to work relentlessly hard every
day and then you go on vacation you know
you go to all all-inclusive resort for a
week and then you go back to the so but
I think something I've changed in my
lifestyle is everyday making small
choices that are self-care so whether
it's met it before each of my tapings
today I had 10 minutes of meditation
before that I said I like my incense I
listen to meditation music on my
headphones and I first start by crossing
my legs and trying to sit up straight
with posture and I just do some
breathing and I just take deep breaths
very calmly very slowly I take deep
breaths for a couple of minutes try to
clear my mind just anger my skin and
take care of my body and feeling
hydrated things that I was really bad at
before right and that's the thing that
you have to learn and yep
it sounds common sense but for me it
wasn't I was very much so like every
moment of the day has to go towards
email or script writing or reading this
or that but no it's it's actually good
to practice self-care every day little
ways as an advocate for mental house
Lily used the time off to reenter gize
and reflect on all aspects of her life
including the decision to publicly
identify herself as bisexual on Twitter
saying quote female coloured bisexual
throughout my life these have proven to
be obstacles from time to time but now
I'm fully embracing them as my
superpowers no matter how many boxes you
check I encourage you to do the same
when you came out I said you know I am
bi oh you had a tremendous response
right yes he's expecting that um I mean
I was expecting a response and I knew
that people would be supportive and I
knew some people would not like that I
ultimately decided I don't care but I
have to say that the response was
overwhelmingly positive I wasn't
expecting that positive response to the
point where my very next meet-and-greet
that was in India which I'm super candid
like that's stressful you know there's
there's a lot of people from our culture
that are not in support of the lgbtq+
community there's a lot of are but
there's a lot of people that or not and
so I was definitely stressed about that
but at my meet and greet can genuinely
say like 50 percent of people came out
to me different of my fans came out to
me in person during that meeting so what
does it mean to you to know that like
that's how strong the connection that
people have - it's a hard thing to
digest if I'm honest because how I view
things is if someone comes up to me and
says you've really changed my life I
view it in a way where like I didn't
like you changed your life and I was
just there
[Music]